soir ex isère pour le sait ça cédric 6r
scan l'aktu donc cédric scan là que tu
viens de comprendre c'est ça merci c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu un très très gros
succès hier vous nous l'avait réclamé
encore aujourd'hui je peux vous dire on
a dû le payer très cher pour qu'il
vienne faire sa chronique c'est vrai 25
euros 50
ça fait plaisir merci beaucoup alors je
suis revenu syrie parce qu' hier j'avais
encore plein de choses à dire sur
ballons ce compost évidemment cost grand
débat on se rappelle tous avec marlène
schiappa ai eu plein de propositions de
français qui ont été transmises au
gouvernement et moi j'ai beaucoup aimé
celle ci regardez la profession comme
matthieu delormeau arrête sa carrière
d'animateur alors je rappelle que
vendredi vous recevez madame la ministre
madame annie de varennes chapa alors
hier on avait vu que votre relation avec
madame la ministre c'est un petit peu je
t'aime moi non plus un petit peu comme
francesca et mathieu alors vous allez
voir que la ministre a fait une patrick
bruel elle s'est cassé la voix pourtant
début de soirée elle avait une voix à
cristalline soirée merci de m'accueillir
merci à vous déjà s'il parce que vous
n'étiez pas obligé d'y un oui à ma
proposition mais demeure après c'est
plus la même et m'a fait penser à cette
personne d'ailleurs on a enrichi les uns
les propositions des autres c'est un peu
marge simpson ont regardé comme ça elle
a placé des cases dédiées à ces poteaux
calme comme ça pardon adrien qu'on salue
qui nous regardent qui a qui en
viendraient trop celle adrian est longue
et on a vu que pour éviter qu'elles vous
tous vous avez pris vos distances
souvenez vous il ya toujours les plus
tard en france
la pire erreur qu'on sera dépendant les
marlène a quand même réussi à vous
attraper c'est incroyable regarder le
temps le bras ce soir vous avez un
copain qui ressemble en place cyril
hanouna booba d'ailleurs c'est que vous
n'avez vous étonner
prenez quelques années alors pour la
prochaine venue de marlène schiappa
cyril on a livré une toute nouvelle
table regardez-moi ça
[Musique]
en une soirée vous faites plus d'antenne
que patrick sabatier en 20 ans est ce
que vous le vendredi pendant pendant les
sept heures d'émission de btp vous êtes
en pleine forme je n'avais pas une once
de fatigue c'est incroyable mais vrai
mais ce n'est pas le cas de tout le
monde
[Applaudissements]
alors tout le monde qui fait surtout
jeanine ont regardé qui s'éclate changer
des règles et des autres
les équipes et tous les chroniqueurs se
disent dire qu'à la réunion de tout à
l'heure il nous a dit vous finirez à
00h30 bien sûr l'heure alors le public
commence à avoir du mal
voyez sur lle ça me nourrit des musées
le payer du gouvernement qui prétend que
la réforme qui l'a opéré et la régie 2c
vite c'est carrément transformé en
dortoir
c'est vrai c'est le dj démissionner et
puis si à la fin vous avez perdu tout le
monde absolument tout mais en plus je
préfère vite parce qu'on est sur ces
[Applaudissements]
faits 3h22 alors savais que je parle
souvent de lui parce que c'est mon idole
il s'agit bien sûr de bernard montiel
donne l'aspect brillant surtout que j'ai
grandi avec lui moi quand j'étais petit
je crois que c'est le frère de casimir
j'avais la même couleur
alors sachez que bon bernard s'est pas
seulement l'ami des princes et
patiemment adieu l'ami des duchesses des
patrons du point soleil non si l'avis
des rapporteurs le week-end bernard fait
du rap regardez eu la preuve ça lui
permet alors la semaine dernière quand
vous avez reçu qu'un hack harris et son
frère au charisme et j'ai découvert un
tout nouveau bernard montiel
regardez-moi ça là quand on jamais céder
ma place à vidéo gag puisque j'étais
viré il a dit
partir c'est el watan écrasé mais
combien de caméras quand et à la salle
et avait des maquilleuses tout ça tu
fais du cinéma ont ralenti dans la salle
de sport cela dit il y avait pas grand
mère pas de doute la maire d'aix et à
meilleures interventions alors c'était
dans une séquence qui s'appelle le
rabibochage
alors oui il ya un jingle inoubliable
déjà
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
le single est très bien merci le jingle
est effectivement inoubliable
contrairement à la séquence d'hier soir
qui était un petit peu plus oubliables
un mois ci bouge mignon mignon mais le
problème c'est que vous aviez bien
bosser votre dossier vous allez voir
alors vous êtes soeur jumelle votre rêve
de petite fille était tombée à 1 5 m
mais bon on n'est pas jumelles on est
pas jumelles les lanceurs soeur jumelle
voisin de palier franchement ça paraît
[Applaudissements]
le premier mot c'est pas mal alors c'est
vrai que c'est pas fini parce que vous
voulez rabibocher donc rachel et
séraphine oui à qui se sont pas vu
depuis très longtemps et on va voir sa
réaction vous ne vous êtes pas parlé
depuis combien de temps 5 ans 10 ans en
vingt ans la quelques semaines je t'ai
pas les deux minutes à moi j'ai pris mon
boulanger depuis cet après midi non mais
je suis désolé de vous l'annoncer en
direct ce soir à tous le rabibochage de
rabibocher sera plus jamais personne
non non
paix à son âme quand on se sera pas la
première séquence à rejoindre le
cimetière de la barca a des centaines
alors pour vous remémorer des exemples
de tout ce qu'on a perdu en cinq mois
voici un magnéto ils ont disparu et je
vous demande le plus grand recueillement
syrie chaque soir à mains nues
[Musique]
on va vous passez une séquence est
incroyable et j'ai passé ce jeu
s'appelle babouche ou 104
m
[Musique]
c'est pour ça qu'ils reviennent
bolivienne vote il veut me berthe rossi
travail moitié ça mais je serais
sûrement le prochain disparaître alors
passer une bonne soirée ses portes
[Applaudissements]